if residential towns don't stand a
chance in this war then it was
inevitable this ukraine military air
base in vaseliev would be a target
billowing clouds cloak its remnants
destroyed this morning by yet more
russian rockets
just 20 miles outside of kiev the
russian offensive creeps ever closer to
the capital
u.s satellite company maxar says they've
seen troops actively firing artillery
towards residential areas
russia's defense ministry released this
footage showing troops in chernhiv
allegedly searching for ukrainian
resistance groups
but they aren't convincing ukrainians
themselves in the southern port city of
molitopol this cctv footage appears to
show a man who many believe is the
city's mayor being led away by force
from the city's registry office
sky news has verified this video which
shows protesters demanding his release
they believe he's been kidnapped by
russian troops
free the mayor they chant
president zielinski has implored
international allies to help
we expect the world's leaders to show
how they can influence the situation
that they can do their job just to
release one person such a person who
personified the whole community of
malitapol and the ukrainians who do not
stand on their knees
there are countless reasons ukrainians
are angry inside shelled buildings in
harkev firefighters balance on what's
left of family life they pick through
rubble attempting to rescue whatever
remains after an overnight attack
this is what hundreds of thousands are
living with
in the eastern town of vilnavaka outside
of donesk the elderly make dinner
surrounded by ruin
irina's bedridden mother should have
been with them but the sirens yesterday
sounded almost as soon as the missiles
hit leaving no time for her to move
my mother's heart was very weak she
would have survived if not for this
explosion there was a missile on the
other side
her place of worship is no longer a
place of serenity
neither is the children's playground on
the left-hand side of this video
hallmarks of community continuing to be
destroyed piece by piece
ash nahari naga sky news